[Musik]
die app setzt auf bluetooth auf basiert
aber auf einem sehr simplen protokoll wo
quasi zwischen den geräten nicht
wirklich kommuniziert wird es wird immer
nur in den wald gerufen und wenn es
jemand hört antwortet dieses gerät nicht
wirklich so dass die geräte nicht
miteinander in eine komplexe interaktion
treten also das mobiltelefon sendet
einfach in regelmäßigen abständen sich
ändernde codes über bluetooth einfach
nur aus also auch ohne darauf zu achten
ob die jetzt jemand empfängt oder nicht
und in ebenso regelmäßigen aber größeren
abständen empfängt das gerät codes und
die geräte speichern dann die codes die
sie empfangen haben
und wenn sich nun eine person als
infiziert meldet lädt sie ihre codes
hoch und alle anderen geräte schauen
immer an dieser zentralen stelle welche
codes sich als infiziert gemeldet haben
um dann lokal den abgleich zu machen
habe ich kontakt gab zu einer
infizierten person oder nicht
wie weit diese app verbreitet sein muss
ist eine frage für epidemiologie und
epidemiologen ich weiß aber dass davon
ausgegangen wird die app würde nur
denjenigen menschen nutzen und nur
denjenigen menschen helfen und sie
schützen
diese app nutzen dass es tatsächlich
nicht der fall diese app hilft den
kontakten von kontakten von infizierten
also wenn ich infiziert bin konnte die
app mir nicht mehr helfen wenn ich zu
ihnen zu diesem zeitpunkt schon kontakt
hatte konnte diese app auch ihnen nicht
mehr helfen
wenn sie aber nun den alarm bekommen sie
das ich infiziert war sie kontakt mit
einer infizierten person hat und sie nun
ihre kontakte reduzieren
dann helfen sie menschen sich nicht zu
infizieren
unabhängig davon ob diese menschen die
app nutzen oder nicht
[Musik]
es ist nie auszuschließen dass es
irgendwo noch schwachstellen gibt das
ist das traurige wesen der it-sicherheit
durch die dezentralität und durch die
datensparsamkeit wird aber das risiko
stark minimiert das heißt jeder angriff
der jetzt noch demonstriert wird oder
werden könnte wäre von sehr viel
schwerwiegend dar im ausmaß wäre die
bundesregierung dem ursprünglich
verfolgte zentralen ansatz gefolgt wenn
ich mir nun die durchschnittliche
deutsche person vorstellen die auf einem
android handy von google mehrere stunden
am tag mit facebook und whatsapp
verbringt dann ist im zweifelsfall davon
auszugehen dass für diese person diese
bluetooth basierte contact racing ab
doch eher nur eine sekundäre sorge für
ihre privatsphäre gehen
es ist tatsächlich ein häufiges
missverständnis dass die deutsche app
nun besonders spät käme vielmehr ist es
so dass viele andere länder apps hatten
die zu früh und vielleicht auch früher
reif etabliert wurden
damit so eine app auch im hintergrund
funktioniert muss sie von den
betriebssystemen herstellern
insbesondere von apple unterstützt
werden dh die apps von denen wir im märz
april und mai gehört haben waren alle
nicht unter realen bedingungen auf apple
geräten einsetzbar die ja in deutschland
doch einen signifikanten marktanteil
haben
ich denke wir werden sehen inwiefern der
akku belastet wird bei den geräten aber
meine vorsichtige laienhafte schätzung
wäre dass die leute immer noch ihren
akku sehr viel schneller leer bekommen
mit allen aktivitäten bei denen das
display an es beim chatten beim
musikhören oder sonstigen sodass dieser
mehrverbrauch an akkuleistung sich
vermutlich in einem tolerablen bereich
befinden sollte aber das ergebnis werden
wir dann jetzt bald sehen für uns